Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Barbara
halweg willkommen an diesem Samstagabend
Norma Norbert Lehmann ist auch dabei
einen schönen guten Abend auch von mir
und das sind die Themen von heute
Streit Thema Kindesunterhalt wer sich
mit um den Nachwuchs kümmert soll
künftig weniger zahlen müssen
Krieg gegen Zivilisten bei einem
russischen Angriff auf das Stadtzentrum
von ternehof sterben mindestens sieben
Menschen 129 werden verletzt
nicht billig aber bequem Solaranlagen zu
mieten ersparen Anschaffung Wartung und
Bürokratie haben aber ihren Preis
[Musik]
wenn Eltern sich trennen dann bleiben
die Kinder meist bei der Mutter der
Vater muss Unterhalt zahlen um die
finanziellen Lasten der Kinderbetreuung
wäre zu verteilen will Justizminister
Buschmann das Unterhaltsrecht ändern
wenn sich zum Beispiel ein Vater nach
der Trennung regelmäßig in größerem
Umfang an der Betreuung beteiligt soll
er weniger zahlen müssen mattes Feldhoff
und henriet sehr
was ist gerecht was ist gerechtfertigt
wo beginnt die Ungerechtigkeit die
Geschichte des kinderunterhaltes ist
eine Geschichte vom Streit zwischen
Ex-Partnern ums Geld von Klagen und
Enttäuschungen auf dem Tag der offenen
Tür der Bundesregierung verteidigt
Justizminister Buschmann seine Reform
des Kinder Unterhalts Kern des
Vorschlages die Betreuungsleistung soll
sich im Unterhalt widerspiegeln das
macht nach dem jetzigen Unterhaltsrecht
keinen Unterschied für die
Unterhaltspflicht ob beispielsweise der
weniger betreuende Elternteil sich an
einem oder an drei Tagen in der Woche um
das Kind kümmert und das ist natürlich
unfair ein Beispiel ein Vater der 4000 €
netto verdient und sein Kind zu 40%
betreut sowie eine Mutter die nur 2000 €
hat aber 60% Betreuung leistet derzeit
zahlt der Vater mehr als 500 € bei
Anrechnung der Erziehungsleistung könnte
er rund 100 € Rabatt bekommen
Minister Buschmann sagt voraus weniger
Unterhalt werden sich mehr
Erwerbstätigkeit aufgefangen die
betroffenen Verbände Glauben daran nicht
wir finden das überhaupt nicht fair
schon jetzt ist ja jedes zweite Kind von
in einer ein elternfamilie von Armut
betroffen wenn jetzt noch weniger
Unterhalt reinkommt dann ist das
wirklich sehr unfair für die Kinder
Familienministerin Paulus ist bemüht
nicht schon wieder Öl ins Ampel Feuer zu
gießen Buschmanns Vorschlag kennt sie
noch nicht
von daher freue ich mich dass die
Eckpunkte jetzt vorliegen bin ganz
sicher dass wir auch in der nächsten
Woche dann bekommen werden und es dann
genau ein Bild machen können um
gemeinsam als Koalition dann diese
Reform auf den Weg zu bringen Minister
Buschmann verspricht eine offene und
breite Debatte in der Regierung und mit
dem Betroffenen
einen günstigen
industriestrompreis für energieintensive
Unternehmen bislang lehnt Kanzler Scholz
diese Idee ab doch es gibt immer mehr
Befürworter in der eigenen Partei
ansonsten drohe ein Substanzverlust war
Niedersachsens Ministerpräsident weil
SPD in der Welt am Sonntag eine
dehnustrialisierung könne sich das Land
nicht leisten hintergrund ist der
Vorschlag von Wirtschaftsminister Habeck
den Strompreis für bestimmte Branchen zu
decken
es ist Tag
542 im russischen Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine ein ganz gewöhnlicher
Samstag den Russland in einen Tag des
Schmerzes und das Verlusts verwandelt
hat so kommentiert Präsident silenski
einen Angriff auf die Stadt terniehe
russische Raketen treffen das Zentrum
der Stadt im Norden von Kiew sieben
Menschen sterben nach Regierungsangaben
mindestens 129 werden verletzt Julia
Schröter
Trümmer Scherben Rauch Tote und
Verletzte die russische Rakete ist
mitten im Zentrum der Stadt jenny-hif
eingeschlagen einer Großstadt rund 150
km nördlich der Hauptstadt Kiel der
Marschflugkörper hat mehrere Gebäude
beschädigt darunter die Universität und
ein Theater
wir standen hier und eine Rakete flog
über uns dann hörten wir eine Explosion
wir sahen den Rauch und sind sofort
gekommen um zu helfen
ein Angriff an einem Ort der zuletzt
verschont geblieben war ein Teil der
Opfer wurde wegen eines Feiertags
offenbar auf dem Weg zur Kirche
überrascht
Präsident selenski erfährt von dem
Raketenangriff auf Auslandsreise er ist
in Schweden das skandinavische Land
unterstützt die Ukraine bereits mit
Waffen nun geht es auch um Kampfjets um
das Modell Grieben aus dem Hause SAB ich
hole wir haben heute im Detail über die
Möglichkeit gesprochen kritenjets zu
bekommen
unsere Freiheit zu verteidigen
ukrainische Piloten haben bereits
begonnen Testflüge damit zu machen
äh Ukraine während selensky im Ausland
um Unterstützung wird reist Präsident
Putin im eigenen Land diese Bilder
sollen ihnen im südrussischen Roßdorf am
Don zeigen dem Hauptquartier der
sogenannten spezialoperation gemeinsam
mit Generalstabschef gerassimov trifft
er sich mit Kommandeuren einen Grund für
den Besuch nannte der Kreml nicht doch
eine Botschafter Bilder könnte diese
sein putin will zeigen ich kümmere mich
und habe alles im Griff
der russische Präsident nimmt keine
Rücksicht auf Zivilisten das zeigen die
Angriffe auf Wohnhäuser Kliniken und
Universitäten darüber hinaus schickt er
offenbar gezielt Raketen ins Herz der
ukrainischen Kultur die Hafenstadt
Odessa galt als Perle des schwarzen
Meers erst im Januar wurde das Zentrum
der Stadt ins Weltkulturerbe aufgenommen
mittlerweile sind Kathedrale und Museen
schwer beschädigt eine Brühl war dort
an der orthodoxen Kathedrale reparieren
sie schon das Dach Schäden überall auch
am Haus der Wissenschaftler es gehörte
eins der Familie trotz treu und ist
eines der berühmtesten historischen
Gebäude in Odessa
der letzte Angriff vom 23 juli hat ganz
spezifisch im Stadtzentrum gegolten die
ganze Stadt ist ja jetzt auf der Welt
erbeliste der UNESCO alle wissen dass
und auch die Russen wussten das
das Museum der bildenden Künste besitzt
Gemälde und Skulpturen ab dem 16
Jahrhundert ein wichtiger Teil der
ukrainischen Identität glaubt der
Kurator
wenn wir sie verlieren dann fehlt uns
möglicherweise auch das Verständnis für
den immateriellen teil und die
ukrainische Kultur wird aussterben
ihre wertvolle Sammlung haben sie gleich
zu Anfang des Kriegs ausgelagert an
einen sicheren Ort stattdessen zeigen
Sie moderne Kunst die Ausstellung heißt
die Sprache des Kriegs
wir sehen hier Künstler aus
lewisse die den Krieg erleben und über
die Themen des Kriegs Nachdenken über
sehr schmerzhafte Themen
es hilft bei all dem was in der Realität
passiert nicht den Kopf zu verlieren und
deshalb und seine Kulturgüter sind in
Gefahr die Schäden im Inneren der
Kathedrale lassen sich so schnell nicht
beseitigen
Kanada kämpft weiter mit der schlimmsten
Waldbrandsaison seiner Geschichte rund
14 Millionen Hektar Wald sind in diesem
Jahr bereits verbrannt besonders bedroht
ist derzeit yellow knife die Hauptstadt
des
nordwest-territoriums tausende Einwohner
mussten dort binnen 48 Stunden ihr zu
Hause verlassen in der Provinz Columbia
um die Stadt Cologne haben die Flammen
bereits etliche Häuser und Wohnungen
zerstört hier wurde der Notstand
ausgerufen Claudia Bates
sie stehen fassungslos am Yachthafen und
müssen beobachten wie das Feuer
unerbittlich auf sie zukommt die
riesigen Brände haben die Stadt kilona
schon fast erreicht eine beträchtliche
Anzahl von Häusern sei bereits
niedergebrannt das Feuer breitet sich
rasend schnell aus seine Fläche hat sich
innerhalb eines Tages verzehnfacht die
Provinz British Columbia hat den
Notstand ausgerufen tausende Menschen
ergreifen die Flucht versuchen sich noch
rechtzeitig in Sicherheit zu bringen
wir sind konfrontiert mit der
schlimmsten Waldbrand Saison in der
Geschichte unserer Provinz heute hat
sich die niedergewiesene Situation
weiter zugespitzt nur weg hier das
müssen die Menschen auch weiter im
Norden Kanadas in yellow knife direkt
neben der Straße schlagen Ihnen schon
die Flammen entgegen
während das Feuer sich durch die
riesigen Waldflächen frisst war die
gesamte Bevölkerung von Yellow knife
aufgefordert die Stadt zu verlassen 19
von 20.000 Einwohnern sind bereits vor
dem Inferno geflüchtet
beängstigend ich muss die ganze Zeit
weinen ich weiß ja nicht mal wie lang
wir weg sein werden
hilflose Versuche die Häuser zu sichern
bevor das Feuer kommt
dabei kämpft selbst die Feuerwehr auf
fast verlorenem Posten die Brände haben
schon mehrere Brandschneisen
übersprungen sie werden noch lange nicht
unter Kontrolle sein
gestern erst hatte US-Präsident beiden
mit Japan und Südkorea eine engere
Zusammenarbeit in Militär und
Sicherheitsfragen vereinbart als
Gegengewicht zu Chinas vormacht Streben
im indopazifischen Raum
China demonstrierte heute wieder
militärische Stärke bei einem
Militärmanöver nahe Taiwan die Übung mit
Kriegsschiffen und Luftwaffe sei eine
ernste Warnung erklärte China laut
Taiwan Drang Kampfflugzeuge dutzende
Male in die
taiwanesische luftverteidigungszone ein
in Ecuador finden morgen
Präsidentenwahlen statt es sind Wahlen
im Schatten der Gewalt vor gut einer
Woche wurde einer der acht Kandidaten
erschossen seitdem gilt der
Ausnahmezustand in dem südamerikanischen
Land früher galt das rohstoffreiche
Ecuador als stabil und sicher doch nun
prägen Korruption und die Drogenmafia
den Alltag Christoph röckerath
vor lauter Sicherheitskräften hinter
Sturmgewehren und schusssicheren Westen
erkennt man kaum die Kandidaten die
Abschlussveranstaltungen der acht
Bewerberinnen und Bewerber um das Amt
des Präsidenten von Ecuador zeichnen das
Bild einer Demokratie unter Beschuss
auch die meisten Bürger haben Angst nur
wenige wollen vor der Kamera mit uns
reden
sehr bedauerlich alles die Lage ist
chaotisch extrem unsicher viel Gewalt
man kann nicht ruhig durch die Straßen
gehen
die Institutionen haben uns im Stich
gelassen es fehlt ein hartes Vorgehen
gut eine Woche ist es her dass einer der
Kandidaten Fernando via wie sensio auf
offener Straße ermordet wurde die
Hintergründe sind unklar doch er hatte
wiederholt Korruption und organisiertes
Verbrechen angeprangert bei der
Trauerfeier entladen sich Wut und
Frustration
jetzt passt die Polizei auf aber wenn
man sie braucht ist sie nicht da bis vor
wenigen Jahren galt Ecuador als eines
der sichersten Länder Südamerikas
inzwischen aber ist es zu einem der
wichtigsten Drehkreuze des
internationalen Drogenhandels geworden
vor allem von der Hafenstadt goiakiel
aus organisieren die Kartelle den Kokain
schmuggeln nach Europa den Aufstieg des
organisierten Verbrechens erklären
Experten unter anderem mit einer
verfehlten Sicherheitspolitik
die Politik verweigert sich der Realität
lieber suchen die Politiker kleine
Vorteile für sich in einer Dynamik links
gegen Rechts anstatt nach einer
ernsthaften Lösung zu suchen für dieses
Problem das täglich Menschenleben kostet
innere Sicherheit ist nun das Top-Thema
bei der Präsidentschaftswahl am morgigen
Sonntag
[Applaus]
Ende Juli hatte das Militär in Niger den
demokratisch gewählten Präsidenten
gestürzt das will die westafrikanische
Staatengemeinschaft Eco was nicht
akzeptieren und hat deshalb eine
Verhandlungsdelegation in die nikrische
Hauptstadt nyane geschickt bereits
gestern hatte sich Eko was zu einem
Militäreinsatz in Niger bereit erklärt
die Truppen sollen zum Einsatz kommen
falls die Verhandlungen scheitern Niger
hat nach eigenen Angaben bereits eine
Verteidigungsstrategie entwickelt
Solaranlagen sind gut für den
Klimaschutz und liefern günstigen Strom
allerdings ist die Anschaffung teuer
eine Alternative sind Solaranlagen zum
Mieten ähnlich dem auto leasing mit
monatlichen Raten Planung Bau und
Wartung übernimmt der Vermieter auf
lange Sicht ist das allerdings nicht
unbedingt günstiger zeigt Hans-jürgen
Piel
Sonnenstrom vom eigenen Dach mit
Photovoltaik unabhängiger von steigenden
Strompreisen werden und das ohne
Anschaffungskosten für Volker aus Berlin
eine willkommene Möglichkeit
zum Monat eine 160 € und für die gesamte
Anlage und hast dafür eine
Stromersparnis und es ist ein
übersichtlicher Kostenfaktor und das war
mit die Entscheidung zu sagen ich kaufe
nicht wenn ich zur Bank hole mir nicht
im Kredit wie ist der Teil wie die
Zinsen funktionieren Firmen wie
Marktführer entpal übernehmen Anmeldung
Installation Versicherung und Wartung
der Strom gehört dem Kunden und nach 20
Jahren auch die Anlage für das Berliner
Startup ging es mit dem mietkaufmodell
steil bergauf seit Gründung
vervielfachten sich die Kunden zahlen
mit fast 50.000 Anlagen und über 1000
Mitarbeitern ist Empire heute größter
solarinstallateur Deutschlands wir haben
uns die Frage gestellt wie muss denn
also ein Produkt sein damit die Mehrheit
der Deutschen sich für eine
Photovoltaikanlage entscheidet und wir
haben verschiedene Produkte ausgetestet
und festgestellt dass die Miete
also die mietkauflösung genau das
Produkt ist längst bieten auch viele
Mitbewerber ähnliche Leistungen
verbraucherschützer raten nachzurechnen
in 20 Jahren summieren sich die
Monatsmieten auf Beträge die eine
Kaufsumme übersteigen können dafür muss
der Kunde sich aber um fast nichts mehr
kümmern man muss sich das genau angucken
die Faustregel ist mieten ist bequem
aber in der Regel teurer wenn man es
selber macht macht es mehr Arbeit man
ist flexibler und das ist dafür dann
aber in der Regel günstiger Volker gut
gewählt trotzdem dabei bleiben hat sich
von seinem solarvermieter auch eine
Wärmepumpe installieren lassen die
allerdings gekauft
ein Massenunfall mit zehn Autos und der
Verdacht auf ein illegales Rennen
beschäftigt die Polizei in Köln dabei
hat er einen 28-jähriger gestern Abend
in Deutz mit hoher Geschwindigkeit eine
Ampel bei Rot überfahren danach raste er
in wartende Fahrzeuge schobt diese
ineinander hob ab und landete auf dem
Dach eines Autos dessen Fahrerin und der
28-Jährige wurden in eine Klinik
gebracht
es ist eine der Attraktionen Floridas
tauchen im Korallenriff dort liegt das
drittgrößte der Welt wenn sich aber das
Meer im Sommer zunehmend bis auf
Badewannentemperatur erhitzt dann stirbt
dieses Naturwunder in Florida versuchen
sie dagegen zu halten indem sie den
Korallen eine Auszeit im kühlen
verschaffen da wird sauer hat Details
Ausfahrt zu den Korallenriffen ganz im
Süden Floridas wir begleiten ein Team
von Experten dass sie Riffe bewahren
will der Golfstrom ist zu warm darunter
leiden die Korallen
wir nehmen Korallen aus dem Meer weil
die Prognosen sagen dass die nächsten
zwei Monate sehr belastend werden
Tauchgang zur unterwassergärtnerei in
zwölf Metern Tiefe mehr als 32 Grad
Wassertemperatur hat es derzeit viel zu
viel das Team sammelt mit feinem
Werkzeug die empfindlichen Korallen ein
am Land werden sie in kühlerem
nährstoffreichem Wasser aufgepäppelt um
irgendwann wieder ausgesetzt zu werden
die Korallen sind hier ein wichtiger
Bestandteil im Kreislauf des Lebens
Fische Algen Krebse alles hängt
miteinander zusammen
wir verlieren im nächsten halben
Jahrhundert die Riffe wenn wir nicht
handeln ein ganzes Ökosystem das gab es
noch nie in der Geschichte der
Menschheit
Ausladen in der weltgrößten Korallen
Aufzuchtstation gute Ausbeute 1500 Stück
sind es diesmal aber den Niedergang der
Riffe können auch diese Bemühungen
langfristig wohl nicht aufhalten dabei
ist die Unterwasserwelt im
Taucherparadies Florida auch ein
Wirtschaftsfaktor die vielen
Tauchschulen bangen um ihr Geschäft
das drittgrößte Riff der Welt das ist
unser Lebenselixier ohne das war's das
mit unserem Geschäft ich will nicht dass
die Menschen hier tauchen kommen nur um
das Riff noch ein letztes Mal zu sehen
jeden Tag erwärmt sich das Meer aktuell
weiter jeden Tag gleichen Teile des
Riffs aus und Sterben den
korallenrettern geht die Arbeit nicht
aus
jetzt zur Fußball
geholt ja absolut verdient aber leider
wurden halt die Australierinnen für
ihren mitreißenden Turnierauftritt nicht
belohnt 0:2 gegen Abwehr und
konterstarke Schwedinnen der vierte
Platz trotzdem ein großer Erfolg für die
Mathildas
die Skandinavierin gegen in Brisbane
durch den Elfer von fridolina Rolfe in
der 30 Minute in Führung und in der 62
minute war es dann die starke
schwedische Kapitän in kosovara aslani
mit dem Tor zum 2:01 Stand
ja und morgen dann der WM Showdown das
Finale Spanien gegen England für beide
Teams wäre es der erste WM-Titel
Spielkunst Spaniens 1:0 durch Salma die
19-Jährige Lichtgestalt beim
Halbfinal-Sieg gegen Schweden trifft auf
Effizienz der Europameisterin aus
England gegen Australien dominant Russos
3:1
alle sind fit wir haben uns gesteigert
und mehr Selbstvertrauen die Engländerin
müssen sich auf eine heiße Partie
einstellen gegen die furia Rocher die
wilden roten mitnehmerqualitäten
wir werden pressen angreifen und als
Einheit spielen und gegenseitig helfen
Unterstützung für die Leine von Englands
Kapitän holt den Kap nach Hause
morgen um 12 Uhr also hi nun in Sydney
ja und das Finale live bei uns im ZDF zu
sehen Sportstudio live die Sendung
beginnt um 11 Uhr zum ersten spieltag
der Fußball-Bundesliga da hat Bayern
München nach der Klatsche im Supercup
geliefert allen voran Superstar Harry
Kane mit einem Tor und einen Assist
souveräner 140 gestern Abend in Bremen
und hier die heutigen Ergebnisse
Leverkusen schlägt Leipzig mit 3:2
Augsburg und Gladbach trennen sich viel
zu viel Hoffenheim unterliegt Freiburg
mit 1 zu 2 Stuttgart gewinnt gegen
Bochum mit 5:0 und Wolfsburg besiegt den
Aufsteiger auf aus Heidenheim mit zwei
zu null das Abendspiel Dortmund gegen
Köln
Stuttgart Tabellen erster vor dem Bayern
und das Abendspiel Dortmund gegen Köln
später ausführlich bei uns im Aktuellen
Sportstudio heute schon um 22:15 Uhr zu
Gast Frank Schmidt der Trainer von
Bundesliga Neuling Heidenheim
kurz vor den US Open wieder ein starker
Auftritt von Alexander Zverev er steht
nach dem souverän 2:07 gegen den
Franzosen Adriano im Halbfinale des
Turniers in Centi und trifft dort auf
Novak Djokovic
starker Auftritt der deutschen
hockeyfrauen gestern Abend bei der Heim
EM in Mönchengladbach das dab-team
bezwang Schottland souverän mit 4:0
Sonja Zimmermann mit dem Tor schon in
der ersten Spielminute und dann
Charlotte stoppenhorst setzte in der 54
minute den flusspunkt die Vize
Europameisterin Treffen morgen im
nächsten Gruppenspiel auf England
sebastian kördel hat bei der Segel WM in
den Haar Silber gewonnen der
Titelverteidiger bei den Windsurfern auf
Tragflügeln musste sich nur den
Niederländer Lück von ob Seeland
geschlagen geben die Klasse heißt IQ
voll und gehört im kommenden Jahr zum
olympia-programm der Segler
und gleich bei uns im ZDF ab 19:25 in
Sportstudio live die Leichtathletik WM
in Budapest dann mit dem Norbert
morgen wird's wieder heiß Hitzewarnung
für fast ganz Deutschland Details hat
gleich erst den
terminik begrüßt sie um 10 Uhr heute
journal danke für Ihr Interesse ein
schönes Wochenende noch und bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Reste einer
Kaltfront die überquert uns allmählich
ostwärts und da sind noch Schauer und
Gewitter im Laufe nach der Nacht dabei
und dann kommt ein Hoch näher und
beruhigt das Wetter aber erst einmal der
Blick in die Nacht und dann gibt es im
Osten Schauer und auch Gewitter die
können vereinzelt auch kräftige
ausfallen mit Starkregen ansonsten ganz
im Westen bildet sich Nebel nach Süden
hin klar des auf Temperaturen gehen
zurück auf 14 Grad im Binnenland der
Nordsee ansonsten 20 Grad im Südwesten
oder im Rhein-Main-Gebiet auch 21 Grad
Richtung Osten Richtung Berlin das ist
eine tropische Nacht
und morgen im Tagesverlauf erstmal viel
Sonne über den Bergen Quellwolken und
hier und da können sich dann mal
Gewitter entwickeln nach Südosten hin
gibt es viel Sonnenschein bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 35 Grad hier extreme
Wärmebelastung 23 Grad ganz im Norden
feststen wir schauen auf die nächsten
Tage da gibt es viel Sonnenschein
einzelne Wärmegewitter bis 35 Grad am
Montag und Mittwoch können die Gewitter
doch sehr heftiger werden und damit ein
schöner Abend